jim parsons played a comic book nerd but
did you know he also played a comic book
villain let's take a look at the actor's
surprising super villain voice role of
all the absurd utterly hilarious
characters to come out of the critically
acclaimed cbs sitcom the big bang theory
arguably no more as iconic or as beloved
as jim parsons sheldon cooper sheldon is
a hyper-intelligent physicist working at
caltech alongside his roommate leonard
hofstadter and despite his incredibly
high iq he is constantly unable to grasp
the most basic of social cues
you're in my spot
while sheldon's lack of social grace and
his neurotic habits constantly test the
patience of those closest to him
audiences and critics around the world
fell in love with him eventually leading
to the spin-off series young sheldon
sheldon was a breakthrough role for
parsons who received four prime time
emmy awards for his performance in the
series and was launched into super
stardom almost overnight the character
is so iconic that it's hard to see
persons without immediately thinking of
the big bang theory though that doesn't
mean he hasn't had his fair share of
parts outside of the hit series his
other work includes roles in the likes
of hidden figures extremely wicked
shockingly evil and vile and the boys in
the band to name a few but it's not just
movies one of barson's more unusual
roles came in the animated tv series the
superhero squad show where he played one
of the more formidable members of dr
strange's rogue's gallery the superhero
squad show was produced by marvel
animation based on the marvel superhero
squad line of action figures from hasbro
the series takes many of marvel's most
iconic superheroes and villains and
turns them into hyper cartoonish comedic
parodies of themselves presenting a much
more light-hearted take on their comic
source material in the series jim
parsons voiced a super villain nightmare
one of dr strange's most iconic rivals
in the comics nightmare is a demonic
ruler of the dream dimension and he
spends his time tormenting sleeping
individuals for fun he has the ability
to manipulate the dreams of others to
the point where he can actually plant
suggestions and thoughts within that
person's mind in order to alter their
behavior it's oddly hilarious to see
this utterly malicious villain turned
into a sillier version of himself in the
superhero squad show and parsons does an
excellent job of emphasizing just how
ridiculous nightmare's powers truly can
be
indeed considering the fact that the
actor barely alters his voice for the
role it's almost as if marvel got
sheldon cooper to play the part and the
result is absolutely hysterical oh hello
villain why would i i mean
what's in it from war it appears that
big bang theory and superhero property
connection is alive and well because
parsons isn't the only cast member to
land a comic book role his co-star mayan
bialik who played sheldon's future wife
amy once provided voice roles for the
2003 video game x2 wolverines revenge
over a decade later she returned to the
world of superheroes providing the voice
of lady lightning for the animated movie
stan lee's mighty seven
however bialik isn't the only big bang
theory lady to get in on the superhero
bandwagon in fact two of the main female
stars throughout the series have gone on
to voice a character from the dc comics
universe harley quinn
most notably kaylie cuoco who played
penny on the big bang theory for all 12
seasons plays the anti-heroine on the
hbo max series harley quinn all she
wants is to be the best bad guy around
and along the way she may just
rediscover what it means to truly be in
love meanwhile melissa rausch who played
bernadette on the big bang theory
starting in 2009 also voiced harley for
a short period of time she lent her
voice-over talents to the iconic
character for the 2017 animated film
batman and harley quinn it seems as
though the big bang theory cast has
somewhat of a knack for playing villains
in fact there's one more main cast
member who got in on the villain fun you
may not realize howard actor simon
helberg plays third-rate super villain
moist in the 2008 web series dr
horrible's sing-along blog after years
of playing nerds and geeks it should
come as no surprise that this is one
cast that's great at playing super
powered individuals
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]